good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday hope
everybody's having a great day hey ja
how you D I'm ding good because I just
pulled a little prank on you right
before we started recording just a teeny
tiny one don't spoil it I'm going to
clip it we actually got it on camera it
was one of the dumbest things ever and
you got me you got
me classic stuff classic classic song
Classic jackon Claud man hey Jax how you
doing I'm doing good I'm excited I'm
going to see you later today wo wo can I
get a woop woo can I get a woop woo cuz
I'm coming to New York for the rest of
the week so we'll be together in studio
OG original recipe I'm officially 31 and
I had a really lovely
birthday
and it's over now you know that's the
thing about birthdays they come and then
they go but what I like about my
birthday obviously and the older that
you get like the less import you place
on it but it does force me to like stop
in my tracks and like reflect on my life
and especially like throughout the day I
keep having to be like oh it's my
birthday like let me be present so that
was very nice a coner reminder I
couldn't do that every day but it was
really nice to do it yesterday and just
to pause and be like I'm enjoying myself
that's nice yeah well I loved
celebrating you and Jakey yesterday I
think you like celebrating Jakey more
honestly um and update from yesterday's
episode You Are present has been secured
I think I crushed it honestly I'm
excited to see what you got me it's
always like obviously I get a gift
that's exciting but also to see what
people think of me is exciting yeah I
think you're going to open this gift and
be like Oh my sister thinks highly of me
I love that for me I think I hope I
don't want to over you know maybe I
should underplay it like no it sucks no
let's hype ourselves up tury L let's get
excited about things tury
tury tur turtle
turtle we have a gorgeous show today
because you're here and I'm here and
we're both supermodels therefore the
episode will be gorgeous and that's just
girl math for you girl
math what are your thoughts on the girl
oh wait we need to talk about something
I'm sure you don't know this cuz like
you're not like a like an insane person
who spends as much time on the internet
as I do but we have fallen into some
sort of conspiracy theory there is
something being theorized about us
tell me so last week there was like a
story going around I don't think it was
like major news I I have I think I know
what you're going to say not as exciting
as I thought it was going to be like a
real conspiracy theory about Travis
Kel's publicist yeah that were like
covering for her yeah okay so the story
last week that we didn't make a story I
did you know about it last week I had
seen it like maybe on Instagram I saw
like a screenshot of it or maybe even it
was in the news I never clicked it I
just didn't care I had a feeling I had
seen it obviously and if I sometimes
there's a story that like I know you
might not see and I always send it to
you being like I'll explain it to you on
the toes yes you didn't send me it I
didn't do that with the Travis Kelce
publicist story because honestly like I
I don't know what the result was like I
don't know what happened there so I I I
also like I just didn't think it was
that crazy but the story was that like
Travis Kel's publicist it was her
birthday and on her private in not
private her personal Instagram story she
re-shared a photo that her friend posted
of her like a collage that was like oh
happy birthday piaia you're our Roman
Empire and in the collage was like a
bunch of pictures of Pia's life and
there was a picture of Travis and Kelsey
in it because she's obviously Travis's
publicist and the picture of Taylor had
a clown Emoji over Taylor's face in the
picture Travis and Kelsey and I believe
Pia was in the background why he keep
saying Travis and Kelsey oh my God I'm
sorry Travis and Taylor Travis and
Taylor and P is in the background okay
and then she put a clown Emoji over
Taylor's face we don't know if Pia rehar
the story and then put the clown emoji
on top or if the clown Emoji was there
originally like we don't know
that okay that's important facts way and
then obviously the swifties found it
immediately the girl made her Instagram
private like there was people were
freaking out like why would her
publicist do this and conspiracy
theories were you know Ablaze they're a
PR couple whatever we didn't choose it
as a story there was really no
underlying like strategy there it just
it didn't feel compelling yeah and we
talk about Travis and Taylor every day
so we can't talk about every little
minute story that comes out every day
like we talk about the big ones they
were
there was a game you know whatever we
had just been Travis and and Jason for
Halloween like it was Overkill I didn't
I can't pick a Travis Taylor story every
single day that's really why I agree it
didn't even cross my mind should I pick
it [__] or not I just Breeze past it so
I guess us not choosing it led people to
spiral and they were like well we know
that Claudia knows Travis's publicist
cuz you said
that we know that Claudia knows Travis
is publicist she's probably trying to
cover for Pia I think that you were
trying to cover for piaia okay I think
that you were because she's a dear dear
friend of yours and you know that she
was really struggling because she thinks
Taylor's a clown so I just wanted to
come on here today and clear my name I
don't know Pia I have never met Pia and
now people are going to be like Claudia
you're misremembering you did meet Pia
Cody rby so Cody rsby was here we were
talking about Taylor Swift and Travis
Kelce and he mentioned that he has the
same publicist as Travis Chelsea and
that that publicist was in the room with
us is the publicist in the room with
us she was not okay what yeah the
publicist that came with Cody rsby was a
man I don't know his name he was a
lovely fellow I'm sure he works at the
same PR agency as
Pia so Pia was not here I never met Pia
I don't really even know Cody's male
publicist I couldn't even tell you his
name he was so lovely saw him in the
room yeah and he brought a few people
with him room with us he was in the room
with us he brought uh his assistant who
was a toaster a lovely gal and this male
publicist I never met P I do not know
Pia I stand by all of those statements
and we were not covering up for Pia you
guys I have to tell you we've been
covering for
Pia I personally was covering for Pia
because P doesn't like Taylor you guys
are right and um
she didn't think anyone would see her
Instagram story because that's how it
works right you never would see that and
so she posted it to her public account
some of the thickheaded people who might
hear this she posted it to her public
account thinking no one would ever see
it might not know that you're joking so
all that to say there is no conspiracy
but I do love some of these conspiracy
theories that come out about us because
they really make us look so good like so
important and influ hobnob in and
covering up for you know the elite I
love it yeah like this whole PR
relationship is going to fall through if
the toast like puts it on blast cuz
we're powerful Jacks I agree don't you
forget it I agree a a conspiracy like
that shines a nice light on us usually
the conspiracy about us like give us a
lot more credit than we have they're
like they did this because of this I'm
like girl we just like woke up and were
ourselves but okay no it's so true we
just woke up and they think we're like
masterminds they think we're so like
powerful back channeling maybe cuz we're
je oh my God
anti-Semitism it's like oh they
definitely you know met Pia I don't even
know if Pia is Jewish they met Pia at
the weekly Jew meeting underground no
it's like you know we just have this
cabal that we're involved in oh my God
like we're controlling the media Jackie
it's giving anti-Semitism I love that it
is yeah the almighty Jews and their big
podcast and their big podcast that's a
great title The Almighty Jews and their
big podcast you know it goes It goes
against my internal policy because it's
a little too long but today I will allow
it when it's a really good title I make
tury makes space on her curds for the
long title when the podcast episodes are
so long like when you're searching the
podcast store sorry yeah no that long
episodes are good when the titles are so
long not only does it like look so bad
on my Photoshop Graphics that we post
Every Day on in stagram stories and but
it also like when you're scrolling
through the podcast app you can't read
that whole thing so you're just like not
compelled to watch it we always try and
have like a really catchy no it's it's
more so about the Photoshop CD because
you could read that that title is not
too long that you wouldn't be able to
the only thing that would be cut off is
like the date which is fine yeah so I
just I'm very particular about podcast
titles but this one the almighty Jews
and their big podcast is so good so good
speaking of big I will allow it speaking
of big podcasts I'm on a couple other
podcasts this week if you're looking for
your girl yeah I'm on Dr Fox's podcast
you guys know Dr Fox King of the
circlage he was my doctor throughout
this pregnancy who saved my pregnancy
and he has a podcast for Women's Health
so I did two episodes with him the first
one came out yesterday and it's all
about me in my story you know like he
didn't know I was a canceled person
like yeah so I was like just telling
fact that there are people who walk this
Earth and you know what's so funny is
like I was thinking this the other day I
think because I was listening to ation
era and this just happens all the time
we always talk about this like when
somebody gets canceled it is the biggest
deal in the world for about an hour it
is or depending on how bad it is ours
was like really like 3 four days yeah
nothing else would happen in the world
until I think it was like the Oscars
that weekend no I know who it was and
even though he was canceled for doing
something bad I will always think of him
fondle who because he finally cycled us
out of the new cycle who Mario
Bali oh inappropriate like workplace
Behavior at his restaurants yeah I I was
just I was grateful for the distraction
I didn't know that we cross pathed on
the cancellation timeline we did on the
[Laughter]
trail but I was thinking about this the
other day because like remember in that
whole Taylor Swift video like it was so
crazy literally who cares like it was so
dumb and I was thinking like I can't
believe she just she took all that time
off and then this big album and it was
like what was the crime she was canceled
for and it was like this stupid video
like who [__] cares and that happens all
the time like in hindsight you realize
how stupid it was and I feel like for us
I had the same experience like now I
look back on it and I'm like oh my God
like really our tweets like get a grip
yeah but in that moment I was like I
should go to jail like for life that's
how people really made me feel I was
like I am the worst person like
seriously I should be I should be shot
yeah that's how I felt jail and it's by
the way it's so con consistent like that
really cuz you know who I'm feeling that
with like because she's been really
slowly I think very strategically like
making a comeback is lizo huh and I'm
like wait what was it again like it just
no matter what happens like that's the
cycle unless you do something like hella
illegal like Chris Brown like goodbye
forever like but I'm talking about like
you know acting inappropriate or like
nothing acting inappropriate it's like
we always say like saying things and
doing things so the acting inappropriate
is more of a doing and um but a lot of
these like thought crimes right it's
just like so crazy in hindsight and the
lizo stuff was like on the sexual
assault allegation Spectrum yeah it was
on the Spectrum it's it's I think it's
like Up For Debate as to if what she did
is like a crime yeah well they're weird
well they're suing so so she's like been
posting on Tik Tok she's been posting
like random things on Tik Tok I think
she's you know slowly climbing her way
out of it yeah I saw like people were
writing up her Halloween costume I was
like oh so we're just casually engaging
with lizo again yeah yeah and that
happens sometimes I feel like you know
who's been really
interesting anel
Elgort okay because anel Elgort was like
fully accused of
rape and then like a year later nobody
cared Ralph Lauren face of Ralph Lauren
Westside Story went to the Oscars I I
don't think it's fair to say nobody
cared because I feel like his name is
tarnished story didn't even get like
pressed because he was in it yeah so I
don't think nobody cared no no I felt
like there he took time off and then
came back and like there wasn't as much
of conversation about it as there should
have been but now I feel like he's
really like done why now done no nothing
I just feel like he tried for the
comeback and like maybe maybe it it
didn't work because now I feel like I've
like laid him to rest M here lies anel
right rip here lies Shannon and like I
think I think it's having like a a
Resurgence like I think we're done with
him I haven't seen him around right I
haven't seen him I don't know but there
was like a moment in time where he was
like back hobnobbing with TBS he was
trying right yeah so just interesting
yeah it is it's always you know we could
wax poetic about cancel culture the
variations scale of which you know who's
like the current can the translation of
the week which like it's just reading so
off to me who
Ramona oh really yeah she's like you
know she was out of Bravo con she got
fired from her Douglas element Job
durinda saying you know speaking out
against like that she used a slur in
this in this message to the page six
reporter but like we read the message
she did not use a slur yeah no she
definitely wasn't as you know buttoned
up and PC as everyone would like her to
be but she wasn't you know she was
trying to reference something and she's
like an older person and like she still
didn't use the word right right right no
and I think the word is so bad but
there's definitely a difference between
using the slur you know uh what's the
word I'm looking for um intention like
targeted targeting like a person of
color versus trying to reference versus
speaking about the word but even though
she was speaking about the word she
didn't even say the word while she was
speaking about the word no and Andy was
actually asked about it quite a bit at
bravocon like his ask Andy panel and
then on the carpet and he clearly had a
u memorized two lines about it cuz he
kept saying I think we made the right
call but if it was the right call then
it should have been the right call when
she said when it happened when it
happened and I just feel like she's like
taking she's falling on the sword for
that whole article and it just why now
why Ramona now after like 10 year or
more than 10 years of bad behavior now
no it's true there was like very little
Fallout from that Vanity Fair article
when it came to like Executives and
people at the production companies who
like made this sort of environment it's
all on Ramona that's true yeah it's just
it's odd it is odd I also feel like you
can't keep uh a Ramona Singer down yeah
I like I feel like every couple of years
there's like this there she went through
a really bad period I don't even
remember what it what she had done but I
just remember it was bad it was after
black
Shabbat oh
cuz that was bad that was bad that was
really bad that was bad I feel like that
story that she was telling about like
being picked on was referenced in Vanity
Fair again she was she got called a
shika yeah yeah she was telling it again
and I just want to say as a Jews I don't
think there's a greater honor than being
called a shika because being called a
shika like means you're beautiful like
yeah yeah aixa goddess like aixa is a
Yiddish word for Just Like a non-jewish
Woman woman but you don't say it about
an ugly woman no you when you reference
it it's like oh this shika like it's
like oh this beautiful temp temptress of
the non-jewish faith like yeah it's it
really is no one's ever going to call me
a shika not even because I'm not no it's
like you it's just a Vibe it's a VI and
it's and it's a beautiful positive vibe
yeah it's a beautiful positive vibe
that's your Yiddish lesson for the day
yeah shika not a bad word
no
no so where were we we get here how do
we get
out I think we have to sing I know Dr
Fox's podcast no I had to he didn't know
I was a canceled person yeah so the
first episode that dropped yesterday was
all about me was perfect episode to drop
on my birthday like here's a little bio
about y girl and then next week my
second episode drops and it's all about
my pregnancy right so from Dr Fox's
point of view cuz he was like don't you
want to know what I thought of you like
how you were handling it did he call the
the episode between the legs no he said
what does a fox say he could have said
no I don't know what it's called it
didn't come out yet but he
could call his podcast betwix the
legs yeah no cuz that's like his POV you
know cuz he was saying on our podcast
because we're constantly pod swapping
with our doctors he was saying that his
name of his podcast stinks because it's
a mouthful the healthful woman I just
want to say love Dr talk would lay my
life out on the line for him it's one of
the worst names for a podcast of all
time I like it I feel like it sums up
what his podcast is about it's about
healthfulness in women it's a lot about
woman pregnancy stuff but just a lot of
different conditions in general with a
lot of different doctors and experts and
it's a great resource for women it was
what I listened to on the plane to New
York when I was going to get my first
circlage I listened to his episode about
circles so I could like have a modum of
understanding of what was going to be
happening to me he should have called it
The Quiet Woman oh no I think he should
have he should should call it what does
the pop fox say what does the fox wait
pop Fox no no I misspoke okay rude
oh what does the fox say I completely
agree I'll text him yeah let him know
what does the fox
say um so should we yeah I think that we
should have a really busy day ahead of
me and we' circled the drain enough here
yep so without further Ado About the
podcast that I'm on this week here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know and the fast five stories that you
need to know were brought to you by Blue
Nile I have never heard anyone complain
about receiving jewelry as a gift but it
can be tricky to get it right and when
you're investing in a piece for yourself
or for anyone else you want to make sure
that everything about it is absolutely
perfect that's why I want to share what
makes us feel the best about a jewelry
purchase and that's sourcing it from
Blue nile.com Blue Nile offers thousands
of independently graded diamonds and
fine jewelry at prices significantly
below traditional retail whether you're
looking for a bit of Sparkle for for
yourself or a gift for someone special
Blue Nile offers peace of mind with
every purchase with some of the highest
quality standards in the industry you
can design your own earrings for
something custom and fresh or check out
their necklaces for a Timeless essential
I have a pair of really beautiful like
multicolored hoops from Blue Nile
they're just you could tell they're made
really well they're beautiful they were
so fun and easy to shop for Blue Nile is
just a great really reputable website
when spending a lot of money on
something and you want to invest in
something you're going to have forever
like you can't go just anywhere you got
to go to Blue nle and what I love about
by the way is that they have um 30-day
return periods service and repair for
Life discret packaging so if you're
getting it as a gift like they'll never
know when it shows up at the door
they're ethically sourced Diamond Source
diamonds they have a page on their
website about how they Source their
diamonds which is fabulous so you can
have peace of mind so if you have any
questions there jewelry experts are on
hand 247 via phone or chat experience
the ease and convenience of shopping
Blue Nile today at Blue n.com that's
blue n
l.com b l n i l e .c beautiful jewelry
Timeless Essentials ethically sourced
really made very well today's episode is
also brought to you by honey love this
year I'm thankful for honey love because
there's nothing worse than suffering
from an uncomfortable bra or shapewear
honey life love has revolutionized the
bra in shapewear game so say goodbye to
uncomfortable underwire and bulky
Fabrics at trap heat honey loves bras
features supportive bonding that
eliminates the need for underwire
without sacrificing the lift plus
they're made with fabric That's So Soft
that you won't want to take it off their
shapewear uses targeted compression with
fabric so soft and Technology you so you
no longer have to feel like you're
suffocating while wearing effective
shapewear shapewear has been a staple in
my life my entire life but so has
comfort and I have literally worn
shapewear that has seriously almost put
me in the hospital like removing my
organs and I found Honey Love on a
Facebook ad like 5 years ago some of my
favorite shapewear and bras are from
honey love I just trust them as a brand
now like I'll buy anything from them so
visit honey love.com toast to shop their
November sale and let them know that we
sent you when you take the survey so
that feeling when you get home from
taking from a long day and immediately
want to take your bra off with honey
love we don't know that feeling cuz
we're feeling comfortable we're chilling
in our bers we're not feeling
constricted we're Feeling Fabulous going
to a wedding need to wear shapewear
don't worry you don't have to leave the
party early go to the bathroom take off
your shapewear and throw it in the
garbage which I have done literally a
thousand times no honey love is carrying
you through the entire evening cuz
you're feeling Smooth you're feeling
snatched but you're also feeling
comfortable so treat yourself to the
best bras and shapewear on the market
and Save to 50% off sitewide at Honey
love.com toast this month only inventory
is limited and the sale ends soon so
don't miss their best deals of the year
after you purchase they'll ask you where
you heard about honey love please
support our show and tell them we sent
you it's time to ditch the underwire for
good thanks to Honey Love today's
episode is also brought to you by
stamp.com it's been a minute since we
talked about stamps.com and the holiday
season it's rear is wearing its ugly
head so did you forget to add stamps.com
to your holiday wish list this year we
all make mistakes Shady the holidays are
hard enough make things easier with
stamps.com stamps.com has been helping
businesses like yours save time and
money during the holiday rush for 25
years with easy access to USPS and UPS
services and premium rates for all your
postage needs so it's your own personal
post office wherever you are with
stamps.com all you need is a computer
and a printer they even send you a free
scale so you'll have everything you need
to get started now taking care of orders
on the go is even easier with stamps.com
and the mobile app if you need a package
pickup you can easily schedule it
through the dashboard and if you sell
products online stamps.com seamlessly
connects with every major Marketplace
and shopping cart you're getting premium
discounts and supplies at your
fingertips with stamps
so if you're running low you can order
shipping and mailing supplies labels
even printers from their supply store
you're also getting huge carrier
discounts up to 84% off up ups and USPS
rates to help your bottom line plus they
automatically are just telling you the
cheapest and fastest options for
shipping for 25 years stamps.com has
been an indispensable resource for over
a million businesses so give your
business the gift of stamps.com so your
mailing and shipping is covered this
holiday season sign up with promo code
toast for a special offer that includes
a 4-we trial plus free postage and a
digital scale there no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code toast
that's t o St at stamps.com thank you
letter D you're you're welcome jacn
fle first story Megan Fox dives into
complicated relationships in a raw new
book of poems poems that she's released
poems poems so Megan Fox has released a
book of poems called pretty boys are
poisonous and it is her first book it
debuts today and it's taking inspiration
from her own life as well as Her
Imagination she said quote it comes from
a lot of places some of it is literal
while other parts are allegorical some
poems contain a Grim's fairy tale type
element and others serve the same
purpose as memes in online culture all
of it is something women can relate to
she said she turned to writing her whole
life after finding an outlet that her
performing career never provided she
said acting doesn't really allow me to
express myself fully in the way writing
does because I'm reading someone else's
words under someone else's Direction
poetry gives me a space to experience
some catharsis through ART pretty boys
are poisonous explores toxic Dynamics
among other topics as she explains
relationships are
complicated this is so
awesome yeah would you like to hear a
poem okay it's called a beautiful boy is
a deadly
drug this is like so you know like I'm
so not into this Vibe I feel like it's
very you know MGK and Megan it's it's
very like Courtney and Travis like the
drinking of the blood the licking of the
tongues it's very rocker it's very Punk
it's so not me I'm so uninterested but
please yes the PO but it's weird to me
because I feel like it can't really be
that much about MGK because like she's
still with him so if he if he's
poisonous no I'm not saying the poems
are about him I'm saying that aesthetic
that like they have together you know
Blood On Fire Wolf Blood packed you know
like [__] twin flames yeah um a
beautiful boy is a deadly drug by Megan
Fox you are an addiction that no amount
of prayers will ever cure my cries for
Relief floating unheard Into The Ether
you are killing me but my heart Won't
Give You Up This Thread through our past
lives tightly wound around my neck
siphoning my breath to fill your lungs
my hands are bleeding from trying to
free myself you offer me a smile content
to steal my life knowing at least this
way no one else will ever have
me so it seems as though the poems don't
and for me that's a huge poetry faux PA
and I think I know why you chose this
story because you
absolutely have to share the poem you
received yesterday oh that's such a
great segue and a positive turn for this
story yeah um because Dana my best
friend Dana you guys know her love her
she's a redhead she writes me a poem for
my birthday every year and it's like a
really cute thing I think she's been
doing
it maybe since the year we met did she
still post it on your Facebook wall she
only posted on my Facebook wall she
hasn't posted anywhere else literally it
did not get one like yesterday because I
have six Facebook friends actually yeah
the consistency and like the nod to you
know Facebook memorabilia yeah but it
needs to be seen and it needs to be
heard so we need to share it so I told
her like I was going to post it to my
Instagram because like it's so amazing
the world should see it so here's the
poem Dana wrote for my birthday she
writes it every year and it's about my
year here we are here how are we here
another sorry sorry excuse me tury L
starting again sorry Dan how are we here
another year round the sun you know the
drill Jack O turns 31 2023 started
strong the party full of cheer at the
clubhouse in Florida lit on New Year's
days filled with Mickey Mouse in the
Sunshine State redhead's going strong
cuz it's never too late you got your
licence the Tesla you were driving
podcaster and Mom some might call it
thriving then came Passover but instead
of 10 plagues you got a short cervix
diagnosis was vague celebrity Ben Sofer
hooked up a private plane no return
flight in sight this chapter was insane
but the bonus time with you was such a
blessing Harry hangs and Smith lunches
things were progressing then Along Came
Charlie the greatest gift of all Against
All Odds that 9B baby was not small no
it was not now you're a mom of Two and a
famous writer
the camper or the counselor snitch
choose your Fighter the only thing I
want more than your beef stew is to
watch lessons in chemistry and cuddle
with Brew obsessed obsessed she should
write a book of poems now that's a poem
now that's a poem I feel about poetry
the same way I feel about children's
book if it ain't Ryman I buying but
we've also said poetry is incredibly
personal so I think to Megan Fox like
this is very personal and I I wish her
all of the luck in the world and it's
clear you know she's put her heart and
soul and her feelings into this book of
poems and you know what I like a
celebrity doing new things we don't
often get the most beautiful woman in
the world writing a book of poems yeah
she could have written a book of short
stories we get that a lot we do I I
happen to love a book of short stories
if the stories are good and by the way
they have to be funny I don't know why I
don't want to read a short story that's
not funny oh I didn't know people wrote
books of short stories that weren't
hysterical like that's only that's the
only [__] you read but like no you could
have any kind of short story tragic no
not interested the best book of short
stories is Gary janetti like hands down
Tom
seura you know what I actually was like
halfway through Tom seura it's one of
those books that I um just leave
downloaded on my Kindle for like when
I'm on an airplane and I'm run like I
don't have a book to read I I didn't
feel so compelled to finish it like in
one sitting but it's nice to always be
like paging through but I also like I
don't know Tom seura like I don't follow
him I don't listen to his podcast like I
know him as a he's like a famous
comedian but like I know G janetti like
I follow him and I know his husband and
I know his life and and so there's like
a connection there yeah but I imagine if
you're like a really big Tom seura fan
it's like the best book I didn't know
him really except I knew his wife from
her Netflix special I didn't really know
him other than like a podcaster two
bears one cave uh but that was like
enough for me to read his book and
appreciate it and I learned a lot about
him it's very funny also a book of short
stories that I read I think it's called
new teeth and it's a book of short
stories about Parenthood so if you're a
new parent I would recommend that it was
really funny I keep trying to get you to
read you I keep trying to get you to
read this one short story from the book
I gave up I've literally never heard you
mention Beauty and the Beast oh that
does sound familiar yeah it was really
funny I feel like that Meme you know
that Meme of like when someone's trying
to convince their friends to watch
friends and it's like come on bro it's
so funny they picked up a couch and yell
pivot it's so funny it is funny EV it's
funny come on man I'll read that short
story for you yeah yeah yeah I'll send
it your what actually I can't send it
your way I need to like trap you in a
room with my Kindle yeah yeah
yeah um okay congrats Megan mazov
congrats Dana on the best poem ever um
yeah we'll see what she's gotten tour
for us next year you're right poetry is
so personal yeah but that's like my vibe
is like Dana's poetry me and the camer
and the counselor that's poetry I also
love a Hau Cameron counselor's poetry
100% um I a poet the I Amic pentameter
is there so am I a poet and you didn't
even know
it and I didn't even know
it are you ready for our next story I
really am Sabrina Carpenter is in some
trouble with the Brooklyn Catholic
Church yeah did you see the story I did
a Brooklyn Catholic Church is forced to
re bless its altar at after pop singer
Sabrina Carpenter filmed a racy music
video at the century old site a New York
Bishop has taken action against a parish
that allowed Popstar Sabrina Carpenter
to shoot a controversial music video in
a century Old Brooklyn church last week
Brooklyn Bishop Father Robert Brennan
criticized her video for her song
feather which was filmed at the
Annunciation of the Blessed Virgin Mary
Church in the video she wears
exclusively racy Alice and watches
several as she watches several men who
wronged her die at one point she Str
into the church to attend a funeral for
the dead men where she moves through a
number of pastel coffins one of which
includes the inscription rip [__] the
local Bishop was horrified by the
contents of the video and made known his
displeasure with the local Parish that
failed to prevent its filming his
statement read the parish did not follow
Diocesan policy regarding the filming on
Church property which includes a review
of the scenes and script the parish
first claimed that the production
company failed to accurate represent the
video content but an investigation found
that the documents given to the parish
provided sufficient description of
inappropriate behavior unsuitable for a
church Sanctuary due to the last I'm
less I'm less like interested in like
the the church politics yeah no like I'm
less interested in like who to blame and
more so just
like I I hate to sound like such like a
grandma and I'm not even like a
churchgoer but like I like if somebody
did this in a Sho like I would be
horrified like some things are sacred
and like I I love a racy music video
like go for it but I think like if she
had done this like on a set that looked
like a church like I still think it
would be disrespectful it's so much
worse that this is like a centuries old
facility yeah and you know what like I
like I hate to be like such like a like
a I I feel like a like a no no what's
who are the like who are the people who
are always protesting like West like oh
uh westbo Baptist Church I I hate to
sound like a protester from the
Westborough Baptist Church but like
maybe like let's like stop being like
you know like racy and doing everything
like sa religious like this it's
disrespectful to the community but I
also think it's disrespectful to like
good Christians to say that it's a take
that only the Westboro Baptist Church
might have that that's fair like I think
a lot of people would feel this way and
this like happens a bunch you know Megan
Fox a mentioned Megan Fox is constantly
desecrating religions um yeah I think
there's two things one can it can it
stop being like cool to like literally
dance on Graves and um be sacriligious
two though at first I saw that the
church said they kind of duped us and
didn't tell us what the music video was
going to be and I was like oh that's
shady you're like coming into their
place of worship and under false
pretenses but they put fourth document
saying like hey rip [__] like yeah no
by the way things are going to get crazy
it's also on the church they are ahead
of a centuries old church it's not a
it's not like Sabrina's prerogative to
make sure that the church is looked at
in the best light so I think it's it's
twofold here and like the church should
have read through the documents like you
don't want people like dancing on the
altar then say no no of of course like
if we had to find blame like the
production company in Sabrina didn't do
anything wrong in terms of like
Logistics and clearance but it's like
this larger conversation about like how
religion is becoming like an
aesthetic and more often than not like
it's disrespectful and it's like racy
yeah but I feel like okay when you say
it's like an aesthetic it also kind of
reminds me of um like Courtney's wedding
there was a lot of um like Catholic
imagery and some people were offended by
that oh were they that I don't like the
veil was a wedding yeah and also to me
that's like respect like they have the
utmost respect for it like the Virgin
Mary was on her veil yeah what's wrong
with that I don't know I think people
weren't into it which they're it's a
wedding I feel like a wedding is where
you put like all of your religious
iconography energy yeah I'm just saying
like that's
one like so where it an aesthetic I
don't think it's always necessarily a
negative thing if it's like done by
people who have respect for the religion
um and are probably practicing that
religion right but when it's done like
this it's it's wrong yeah no cuz I just
think like if they were in a synagogue
and they were like rabbis and stuff and
like you're in a racy dress like I would
be horrified
horrified so like I have to put myself
in someone else's shoes like I I don't
think it's cool and I think like the the
community if there's outrage like you
know what I understand it it's just not
necessary and furthermore if she really
felt like this was the vibe for her
music video and she couldn't you know go
in another Direction and she should have
made a set of a church instead of
actually like desecrating a historical
landmark I am in agreement all that to
say nobody on the planet is making
better music than Sabrina Carpenter
right now I feel like a feather when you
like so good yeah that's the song for
the music yeah I know I know and then of
course he's one talking nonsense
obsessed love the music I just think the
direction could have been different yeah
I think it's easy to get carried away I
think in Hollywood there's not a lot of
boundaries for anything and you don't
have people around you who are like hey
yikes not our best idea we're not going
to like be canceled and never work again
for this but it's a little tasteless
yeah yeah I agree this isn't like a
criminal offense but it's just like
however other argument like maybe they
want to push the envelope some people
want to push the envelope they want to
get the dases involved yeah and maybe
it's like a larger statement on religion
I don't think that's what's going on
here yeah but there are people who like
you know they weigh into this sort of
controversy and they're like yeah ha
think about it chew on that right yeah
they're trying to make you think yeah I
don't think that's what Sabrina was
doing I think she was just trying to
like trash her exes and pick the wrong
venue yeah also we don't know how much
involvement she had in the you know
location scouting for sure but like
you're up there dancing on the altar
like feel funny you walk into like this
ancient church with all this you know
glass window and you're in like a bikini
I would feel
[Laughter]
weird but maybe I'm different but you
never know maybe the record label she
doesn't feel empowered to speak out like
all this money has been spent on the
that's actually also a definite
possibility she's up there dancing in
her Ries on the Altar and she's feeling
bad yeah we don't know what she's going
through at this time no we
don't so important to think about all
possibilities here agreed
agreed are you ready for our next story
yeah little fashion news because the
cfda awards wait was his third or fourth
third don't worry I know that before the
fourth you have something that you need
to say I to expel
myself
yeah our third story before tyy expells
herself that the cfda awards were last
night oh yeah like I don't remember a
time where like the cfda awards were
like maybe it's because with sag like
there's so little going on but I felt
like it was like a especially fabulous
like attention seeking evening I feel
that way as well I also think maybe it's
cuz it's in New York I feel like in the
past it's like an LA or something really
I feel like it's actually like such a
classic New York event you know what
there's a really great search engine
where we can oh what what's it called
it's called googl.com oh wait 2 oh Googl
Googl Michael golay um I Che I think
you're confusing it with LACMA which
also was this week I'm certainly
confusing it with LACMA that's for damn
sure
lachma which is I want to say the LA
Country Music Awards no it's the Los
Angeles like community of Arts okay yeah
last year it was at Kasa chiani yeah
it's a New York Affair you're confusing
it with lakma I am confusing it with
lakma I can accept that yeah oh yeah and
and the year before it was at the pool
and Grill okay I stand corrected anyways
cfda Awards last night the Oscars of
fashion the stars came out in full force
and ha the way hosted Serena Williams
won an award as did she looked fabulous
everyone really looked quite lovely yeah
it's like a clown free event like I feel
like sometimes people show up places
like trying like the Grammys or the
Oscars like trying to make a statement
do the most get attention and I feel
like a lot of times they end up just you
look like clowns but cfda is like really
high fashion like no one's no one's
messing around yeah it's a clown free
event even the mech Gala gets a little
clown because it's a cost it's like a
themed it's a costume Gala let's not
forget right uh so Kim was there Anne
Hathaway gwenneth palro Serena Williams
Dei Moore Vanessa HUD and she's a funny
one cuz she's always at the high class
events she really sneaks in there she's
got a great publicist I have to imagine
just like oh I'm going to snag an
invitation for my girl Vanessa yeah I
don't know like what strategy like got
her there but I admire it deeply
yeah yeah go Vanessa another another
cancellation that seemed like a big deal
it's so so true question mark
exclamation
point so yeah everyone looked nice so
there was a few honorable mentions I
want to say Morgan Stewart was there she
looked just radiant I think one of my
best dressed is Serena Williams she
looked
fabulous gwenth palro got an award we
love goop goop
fashion
and what was the last oh You' love to
see influencers out here shaking their
thing Danielle Bernstein was invited to
her first award she she went with an
Israeli designer made like a big
statement about bringing the hostages
home slle she looked great slle slay so
a good night for fashion yeah no that's
like a fabulous event like I wouldn't
mind being invited to like I know
literally look at my outfit I'm wearing
leggings and socks
like it's not a possibility but I feel
like that's actually like a really cool
event like I feel like a lot of events
look cool and they're like not fun or
there's really not a lot going on feel
like that's an event cuz we don't really
see a lot that actually is like fun you
think fun yeah I don't know about fun
definitely like cool
prestigious not a bunch of losers in
sight right right hard to get an invite
not a loser in
sight I haven't looked at all the red
carpet looks just like the the you know
the biggest names um I I like Dan
Hathway's look too I thought she looked
really nice yeah no it was a high class
Affair yeah so I hope everyone had a
good time and drink awesome Shooters and
listen to awesome music and soaked up
each other's awesomeness that's that's
like what one can only hope for for you
know for any Affair for any Affair are
you ready for our next story is it the
next story that's brought to you by
Jenny Kane it is perfect timing because
Winter is right around the corner and
our wardrobes definitely needed a
refresh Jenny Kane is a California brand
through and through and their Staples
make getting dressed easier than it's
ever been before think minimalist and
effortless but totally refined from
luxurious Kashmir sweaters and iconic
accessories to elevated versions of all
of your everyday Basics not to mention
the most incredible Home Essentials too
Jenny Kane is here to help you live your
best holiday season yet and for limited
timer listeners get 15% off their first
order when they go to Jenny kane.com and
use code toast for that 15% off I'm in
my seeing the snow before Christmas
Coastal grandmother warm cashmere light
a candle era need a comfy pair of
slippers Jenny Kane is the official
sponsor of seeing the snow before
Christmas she is they are and I just
want to say I've been wearing this
oatmeal sweater probably once a week on
the toast I get so many questions about
where it's from Jenny Kane and The
Oatmeal set I wore last week and once a
week on the toast Jenny Kane a lot of
people wanted to know where Don Kelsey's
cashmere sweater was from Jenny Kane
that Ben wore on the toast she oh my God
I was like she would wear Jenny Kane no
sorry FAA felce FAA felce my fave this
one this season especially sweaters are
the it item and lately we've just been
obsessed with the Kashmir sweaters from
Jenny Kane the Flynn Kashmir sweater
it's a perfect wear anything v-neck the
Kashmir half zip such a cool everyday
staple they've really got everything
from candles to home stuff to slippers
to cashmir sweaters whatever you need
give yourself and your loved ones the
best gift of all Jenny Kane our
listeners get 15% off your first order
when you use code toast at Jenny
kane.com that's 15% off at Jenn i k a y
ne.com code toast let getting dressed be
the be one less thing to worry about
today's episode is also brought to you
by Caraway the holidays are approaching
and you know what that means awkward
family discussions around the table
luckily your beautiful carway pans are
sure to be the topic of conversation
hosting the season just got easier with
their Square wear set from roasting your
first ever turkey to making pancakes for
10 at brunch they have got you covered
at caroway the internet famous kitchen
wear is a staple for any home it comes
in a variety of modern Shades to fit
with any design aesthetic their products
are non-toxic kitchen wear they feature
a chemical-free ceramic coating so you
can be prepared food can be prepared
with peace of mind that no hard to
pronounced chemicals are leeching into
your healthy ingredients and now
introducing their stainless steel
cookware set their most popular product
redesigned with stainless steel to make
your take your meals to the next level
so I obviously have a ton of carway
products but because I have such a
bigger kitchen now I just placed a huge
order for their food storage sets I
never had their bake wear before like
I've been thinking I want to start
making muffins like you need their
muffin tin you need I got it and love
that tin you don't have to spray it I
make Ugg bites in there all the time
they just fall right out I also got um
oven mitts like I now that I have space
I got so much more stuff I I had the
basics before like the frying pan the
Dutch oven the good stuff but I got like
a lot of extra stuff and I'm so excited
about it and I got new colors they had
this sort of I think it was Sage it was
like a green I felt like that was very
very cool for my kitchen oh I love that
for you I have the cream ones but I'm
eyeing the pink collection visit carway
home.com theast to take advantage of
this limited time offer for 10% off your
next purchase this deal is exclusive for
our listeners so visit carway home.com
theast or use code the toast at checkout
carway non-toxic cookware made Modern
thank you latcher you're welcome jaqui
our next story A Little Romance news uh
Chase Stoke says he cried the whole time
during Kelsey ballerina first
headlighting show in her hometown I
chose this story cuz we haven't spoken
about these two in a while and we're due
for an update so Chase Stokes gave us
one at the cfda Fashion Awards red
carpet he spoke to People magazine and
said uh what it was like seeing her
perform in her hometown of mascot
Tennessee he said I'm still recouping my
hearing from how loud it was for her to
go back to her hometown and to sell out
an arena like that stage it was the
coolest thing I cried the whole time he
then shared how special it was to see
her accomplish her dreams in front of
her family
no these two are just like quietly
living quietly Going the Distance like
this is not just like a rebound
relationship anymore no I think a lot of
people thought maybe like you should the
divorce and it might have been like to
start but sometimes like you rebound
with the one and now that enough time
has passed I can officially make this
story about myself because I was with
Kelsey ballerini uh the night of or
maybe the night before her first date
with Chas and she was like I'm actually
going out with someone like kind of
nervous I'm like who and she's like you
really can't tell anyone I'm like oh
okay Chase Stokes I'm like wait obsessed
like so not to like be so Anno like I
knew before everyone else um and then I
had a text from her cuz we were texting
after and we I was like oh my God let me
know how the date goes and she was like
yeah so excited like nervous like not to
make everything about myself but I was
pretty much there and I'm like kind of
the reason they're together I agree so
they should thank you for this and I
actually saw her recently at dinner and
she was like wait like I haven't seen
you since my first date with Chase and
I'm like yes so she remembers too that I
was like an integral part okay good I'm
glad it's a mutual not just by the way
delusional I wouldn't say that she
literally I ran into her at polar bar
and she was like by the way like you
were there like she said it she said it
okay she recognized you yeah yeah okay
that's cool then you're Port of the hory
of this coup I'm P I'm Port of the
horory yeah and by the way I just want
to say like obsessed like I feel like
they're not like annoying and they just
like share their lives but not in a way
that's like hey look at me yeah so
they're like they're not private per se
cuz they like share photos and they like
take Instagram stories together and they
take trips but it's not in like an
annoying thirsty way I totally think
it's legit it's the perfect amount and
they support each other like he's going
to her shows and crying and well and
that's like why everyone's obsessed
because so much of the what Kelsey
shared about her divorce through her
album and then when she went on uh colge
daddy like was that there was the
weirdness because like of her success
and there wasn't like a huge amount of
support and you know he didn't take the
flight to come to the show and so the
fact that chase is at so many shows is
actually impressive when he has like a
career of his own yeah I feel like his
career with OBX is like seasonal you
know they film and then they don't right
and that probably works for her yeah and
she he like does like a lot of offline
work like not offline online work like
he's like a brand ambassador for Armani
and that's like work you know that you
can do from anywhere yeah he's an
influencer he's doing it from from the
road yeah so these two are going strong
I feel like we're almost coming up on a
year of we are proba no January it was
January cuz that's when when I was there
we were at a party and I saw
her okay well we'll keep you posted
about these two I wonder if she wants to
get married again soon yeah or if she's
like scarred yeah but I feel like once
you go into it and like everything goes
wrong you can go into it again because
you're equipped right right so you don't
have to like write it off forever right
you just know like the paperwork right
and what you're looking for
but they're also really young like I
feel like I could see them dating for
like 3 years he's 31 and she's 30 if she
hadn't been like married young I would
say like they're going to get married
but now I don't know how she feels about
the institution considering even before
Morgan like she wasn't really about it
right she said that on her podcast cuz
she's like a child of divorce and she's
she's a child of divorce who's like some
people like their parents divorce like
really affects their love life and like
their adult relationships and some
people I feel like it doesn't like for
me it doesn't no me neither maybe it's
because our dad dropped
dead are you ready for our fifth and
final story a little more romance news I
feel like this is like a story that came
out of Bravo cotton that I didn't see
until this morning and not enough people
are talking about so it's the final
story I'm just feeling kind of like
emotional about it you know it's like
the final story no but it should make
you feel good because it's the last
story that we're going to do separate
it's something
unpredictable but in the end is right I
hope you had the time of your life next
story that we discuss together we will
be
together think about it that way are we
going to hang out tonight or you going
think you're going to be tired no um I
think I'll be good okay cool yeah Fifth
and final story Bravo news not enough
people are talking about it gessa from
Shaz of sunset wants to date hot
Mauricio yansky after his split from
Kyle Richards oh wow Gigi from Shaz of
sunset is interested in pursuing
Mauricio yansy amid his separation from
Kyle Richards she told us weekly at
Bravo con I wouldn't mind going on a
date with Mauricio just putting it out
there yeah he's hot and to that I say
get in line [__] okay oh for sure but
like that's I'm sure it's interesting to
me when Bravo shows cross over that's
not like Housewives Housewives like I
think of like Shaz of sunset with like
thenner pump Ry Southern Charm but like
no Gigi could go for a former house
husband no by the way it's so true cuz I
think there's like a younger generation
of Bravo shows which includes like
summer house winter house shaza Sunset
Southern Charm Banner pump rules but
when you get down to Brass tax some of
those cast members are older than those
on Real Housewives yeah no I just think
of them as like the younger generation
and then the housewives are obviously
like the older like ogj but that's
literally not even true like Shep is the
same age as like some of the house
husbands yeah he just acts like a
teenager that's why we think of him so
young yeah but like Kyle Cook is older
than Aaron
Lei wow wow and that puts things into
perspective so Mauricio is 53 and Gigi's
41 age appropriate We Stand yeah but
he's like holding hands with his dancing
partner and maybe getting back together
with his wife no by the way another
story that came out of Bravo con Kyle
like was on the red carpet and just like
accidentally said and nobody caught it
until after she just said like this
divorce like she said
D damn D for damn and I have to say I
really do feel like Mauricio is dating
his partner even though they said like
they weren't but like I don't hold hands
I barely hold hands like with my husband
like it's a very intimate thing it's
extremely intimate yeah cuz like
clamming so un unless you're at like a
really crowded protest and you need to
like you know lock hands to get through
yeah there's really no reason when
there's no one around you physically to
be holding hands with another person of
the opposite sex yeah I'm not a big
handh holder I'm a like I'm a Linker I
like to link
elbows oh I'm not a Linker I like that
support yeah now that I think we do that
more than hold hands Oh you mean with
your husband I thought you meant like
with other people oh even with other
people I feel I feel like I'm always
like walking and leaning on someone you
know I I don't love holding hands not
because of the intimacy like it's
[__] annoying like I need my hands
it's also for me a hygiene thing I know
that it is for you but I like a link do
you and Ben hold hands well that's what
I'm thinking we do hold hands I don't
love it I prefer like to put my arm
around his like waist oh interesting he
he hates hates that he thinks it's hard
to walk yeah that is hard you have to be
like in lock step like a couple s nice
swimmers I I don't mind putting forth
the extra effort but my husband does
it's like left left right left right
left yeah yeah I like a link so there's
definitely something going going on
between the two of them and I can't lie
I don't hate you know gessa and Mauricio
but I feel like
Mauricio if and when he you know dates
and the divorce is final I don't think
he'll be dipping his toe in the Bravo
Universe I don't feel like he's that
type of house husband no I don't think
so either but as you like to remind us
Shaz is no longer on so right but
they're still part of the Bravo Universe
which I'd love to remind you of which
you love to remind me of so yeah I guess
he's with the partner who do you think
is the most eligible house husband cuz
Mauricio is definitely up there single
or taken no any I have to like sit down
with a list of
them probably someone from New
Jersey yeah I was going to say like Evan
gold I mean I think it's more personal
it's so personal for me obviously like
Evan Golder Jewish King like successful
has a job obsessed um Mauricio yansky of
course Jewish like so mine's very
personal yeah Evan gold Schneider Frank
Katana yeah for me obviously about looks
he's engaged he's engaged to Britney
yeah love Joe
benno I mean would lay my life out on
any of the Jersey Bill Aiden even though
he doesn't seem like the best husband to
no he doesn't but he's rich and he's
funny and cute so yeah yeah I don't know
if I would go for Joe
GGA cuz there's really only room in my
relationship for one star and it's me I
agree it's not because I need to be a
star but it's just a it's too much for
me like I like a bit of quiet I like a
peaceful environment Louie is going to
be a big fat
no Paulie seems nice I don't he seems
nice but I don't know him enough I agree
even though he was on my flight to
bravocon Jeff
fesler you know I he's not really on the
show but I did sit next to him at this
dinner at bravocon and he's really shy
and like really sweet yeah so really
most of the Jersey men he but he has a
wife who's like the big personality and
he definitely like lets her shine and I
love that in a man yeah that's like Joe
benno too right let's go through like
Beverly Hills husbands
PK I I like PK I like PK too Jewish King
I do feel like there's a little bit too
much uncertainty in the finances for me
to choose him yeah no he would be like
my number one but he would definitely be
in the bucket of like if I have a yes
bucket or a no bucket he would be in my
bucket of yes I just I don't know how
long like we're like when is the axe
going to fall on the kemsley finances
like every year there's a story about
them I just heard that he owed like $2
million to a casino like then there was
the guy who apparently like attacked
darit in the Bahamas for owing them
money like there all these stories they
never become a storyline and they never
actually come to fruition like she's
still you know buying the clothes and
living the life like either it's all
fake or something major has to happen I
just feel like because it hasn't
happened it's not going to happen cuz it
would have happened she's been on the
show for so long like it it's been
public like their life has been public
for a while I feel like something would
have happened by the way before the
Scandal I would have put Tom gerardy in
my bucket like supportive Rich King what
we thought he was what we thought we
knew yeah
Ray Huger yes bucket a th% yes Juan
Dixon no correct Jamal Bryant no no
Michael Derby
no Chris Samuels
yes oh oh Chris Samuels is top two yeah
because he's pjam energy and he's so
wealthy yeah Chris will Chris Samuels
yes uh what's canis his husband's Chris
no he's a little too cool for school you
know
yeah Terry Terry Duo 1,000 per Terry Duo
top five Shane Simpson top five he's
deeply
misunderstood he's deeply
misunderstood it's so funny there are
certain franchises that have like no
husbands I know like real roony regular
there's not Tom datino let's go Ro knew
Abe top
three I only saw two episodes oh pet
love he's in my yes bucket but like I
wouldn't marry him he's just not my type
but like he's pom um size husband I
can't get a read on him he's really in
the middle for me uh is that the only
other husband Jenna
Abe yeah I think that's it we could go
to
Miami oh we could go to Miami complex
Dynamics at one point in time Lenny
hawky top of the list now he's top of
the no list he's the [__] on my shoe I
hate him yeah uh
larsa's OG husband would love and
current boyfriend it's a little weird I
know but like he went to bravocon with
her they're so serious no it's insane I
think they have a podcast together they
do yeah Michael Jordan's son yeah he's
literally our age how would you feel if
your father was marrying someone your
age Alexia's new husband yes oh Todd
yeah you know whipped that kid into
shape he needed it yeah he needed it
actually love him mhm um oh Marisol is
married but he's a Steve he's never on
the show and he's new we don't know him
yeah Gertie's husband seems great he's a
firefighter oh obsessed oh other news
out of Bravo kind I like I feel like not
enough people talk about Miami and I
actually recently saw ratings for it it
was in the 300,000 so it's really not
like a big franchise but Gertie was
diagnosed with cancer and she's fully
bald and at bravon she announced that
she's cancer-free
yay it was just a fabulous story that
like no one's talking about oh that's
great I'm sure it'll be on this season I
don't know this season has premiered yet
but also Martina has cancer too oh yes I
guess I would consider Martina a house
wife husband wife partner um house
partner 1,000% in the yes bucket in the
yes bucket she is a No Nonsense kind of
gal she's extremely wealthy and she lets
Julia do whatever the [__] she wants
with her goat obsessed I but I do think
that that's going to stop soon I like
they were I didn't finish last season
but they like were having troubles cuz
Julia was just kind of all over the
place and Martina deserves better yeah
no like you could let your spouse do
whatever you want like within reason and
I feel like Julia was like Towing on the
line of
disrespect yeah like with Adriana and
she was also being annoying like she was
always complaining which is her worst
crime which is her worst crime other
franchisees Dallas has good husbands
when it was on throwback loved Stephanie
hullman's husband Lov
um Court Westcott good man good man
deandra's husband top five deandra's
husband we love a military man
yep they had good husbands you're right
yeah what other franchises Atlanta
atlana Todd
Greg
Greg rest in peace that's like such a
crazy thing I know what other franchises
are there I feel like there's like 10
more oh Salt Lake City
yeah I like Meredith Marx's husband he
would go in my bucket mostly because
he's Jewish um I like Lisa Marlo's
husband
yeah I Heather Gade is not married uh
Whitney's
husband now he's a funny egg he seems
nice he's really supportive yeah I think
he's going to go in my no
bucket he's going to go in my middle
with
um that other guy from Rooney and you
know what there was a time where coach
cha would have been in my yes yeah but
no he had a good head on his shoulders
but we didn't know what lied beneath
beneath the head we didn't know anything
yeah that's a fun game to play I Feel
Like are there more
franchises no I feel like we we hit them
all
okay that's our show there's going to be
like one that we completely forgot and
people are going to be like we did OC we
did New York I'm just saying we did New
Jersey we did LA we did Beverly Hills
we did pomac we did Atlanta we did I we
did them all yeah oh Dubai we don't
watch oh yeah but that's like there's a
bunch of international ones but they
don't all on Bravo but yeah no Dubai's
like the only sanctioned International
one yeah because it's like on peacock
and they were at Bravo con they were at
Bravo con all right that's our show you
guys thank you so much for oh you know
who else goes my bucket Crystal Kung
bov's husband yes very rich very
laid-back you know he lets Crystal do
what she wants she's redesigning the
basement and spending a million dollars
like Jewish King yeah I feel like she
like he wanted to spend more right we
love a man who can loosen the purse
string yeah yeah yeah she was tightening
them yeah cuz she's you know a
responsible Queen yeah no fun thank you
so much for listening to the toast of
the M Morning Show where we deliver the
fast life stories he need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast any where podcast can be
found Spotify iTunes Public Radio cast
all the places list podcast toar view
about a beautiful standing and wickedly
talented we are make sure to give our
big Jew podcast a nice big five-star
review to show your support for the
Jewish people right now okay yes love
you bye love you
bye